A new stream of lava has begun flowing
from the volcano erupting on the Spanish
island of La Palma. The lava is
threatening to engulf more homes
in addition to the hundreds that have
already been damaged or destroyed. But
while the volcano is posing a
serious danger to lives and property,
it's also attracting visitors to the island eager
to see the spectacle of a volcano in action.
Thousands have fled from its destructive force,
but others are attracted. The erupting Cumbre
Vieja is now another tourist attraction on
this holiday isle. Some have traveled to
snap a selfie with an erupting volcano.
"It is a once in a life time opportunity
to see something like this and we just thought it
worth make the journey. So we got the ferry across
in it's absolutely fantastic. It's very sad
seeing the lava going down here because it
looks like it might, it's destroying quite a
lot more houses. But still, it's good to see
the natural beauty of this."
"It is incredible,
there is lot of noise, it is the
power and the beauty of the volcano."
But many island residents are wishing
for an end to the instability.
Thousands have been forced to
evacuate, some have lost everything.
"The land I had is all gone. The inheritance I had
there. The memories of my parents. It's all gone."
Lava continues to devour properties. The moving
molten mass has consumed more than a thousand
buildings in the three weeks since eruptions
began, setting fire to everything in its path.
Recent nights have seen fresh flows from
the fiery mountain, as the unstable cone
collapses and new fissures appear, sending
rivers of magma in different directions.
Cumbre Vieja shows no sign of settling down.